okay you have the chance to party all
night long and raise money for AIDS
health support we're so excited Andrew
Ryan for Aid of AIDS of Nevada so a fan
here to talk about this incredible black
and white event it is the preeminent
event of Las Vegas every year 36 years
running and and this is your baby you've
created this so tell me all about what
what people can expect on Saturday well
I got really lucky because I I stepped
into this five years ago helping plan
this event and you know I've been able
to grow it and it's evolved but you know
it's all about the history of this event
it's all about wearing black and white
and coming out and supporting an
incredible cause it's a local non-profit
and 100 of the money that we raise at
this event stays right here in southern
Nevada oh and see that is so important
because you want to make sure that money
that you spend goes to our community
what's the importance of black and white
you know it's interesting that you asked
that because I spent a little bit of
time doing some research to put together
a great story about that this event
started in the late 80s when community
members saw the need for their to to be
a food pantry for those that were
affected by HIV and AIDS which you know
that was the height of the HIV aids
pandemic right right and so they had a
birthday party and invited their friends
and instead of gifts they asked for
canned food which at the time was black
and white generic canned food
s out of that the party was born and
over the years it's developed and grown
into this avant-garde event you know out
of an apartment now we're at the Virgin
hotels Las Vegas in the theater and we
have thousands of people coming together
all wearing black and white and honoring
that Legacy that is incredible I love
the history black and white of course
looks good on everyone one of the things
I love about this event you said
avant-garde I mean it really is where as
little or as much black and white as you
want it is and people can wear you know
whatever they're comfortable with we
want everyone to be comfortable so the
dress code is easy as much as you want
or as little as you can get away with
aha I love that idea and and you briefly
did mention it it is Saturday it's at
virgin and tickets are still available
they are and you know we have a great
ticket price for general admission we
also still have VIP tickets available
which include drink tickets okay so
there's a VIP and a VIP plus if you want
to have a little bit more fun and I
think there are still some tables
available on our website so if you want
to have that elevated experience and
support a fan that much more okay so
that'll be uh we'll put that link on our
website as well folks so you can get
those tickets if you need to
um and I mean really I mean at the heart
of this and you touched on it is support
for AIDS and that is as much fun as you
can have at these events that have uh
all kinds of performers and food and
drink That's the basis of this event
yeah you know this is a party that we
would like to never have to have but you
know we're not there yet so we we come
together we celebrate this event we have
two major anchor events at afan the AIDS
Walk which of course is more of a
remembrance and an opportunity to look
back at where we've been and see where
we're going but this event is really
just about coming together having a
great time and knowing that you're
making a difference and we all hope that
you will join in because like I said
tickets still available thank you so
much for being on the show bright and
early this morning Saturday night folks
it is the event of the season so thank
you again still available
afanlv.org excellent a fan okay